you will walk cold
[Music]
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
major technological change is happening
all around the world you can see it
everywhere but sometimes when change
happens is actually just history
repeating this is evident in the
electric car in 1900 about 40% of cars
for electric 38 percent ran on steam and
only 22 percent ran on gasoline now as
we approached the 2020s we're
rediscovering the electric car so how
could the electric car be so popular
only to all but vanish by 1935 while
we're most of the first cars electric
and what happened to them in this video
we'll take a look I just want to give a
shout out to Squarespace for helping
make this video possible
Squarespace is one of the easiest ways
to build a website there's nothing to
patch or upgrade ever and it's flexible
the end result looks professional and
the whole process makes building website
easy if you're looking to build your own
website start your free trial today
visit www.dent.umich.edu/license
in 1835 surprisingly this was almost 30
years after the first hydrogen car the
gasoline engine didn't come about until
1817 and the first production car was an
1885 by Karl Benz cars company would
later be known as mercedes-benz Rudolf
diesel would unveil his diesel engine
running on peanut oil at the World's
Fair in Paris 1900
the first few decades of the 1900s would
see the widespread introduction of the
internal combustion engine in a way this
technology was taking on the baton from
the steam engine in the 1800s
yes steam powered cars did exist but
unfortunately they required 45 minutes
to warm up in cold weather and needed to
be topped up with substantial amounts of
water limiting their range there had to
be a better solution the early
gasoline-powered cars were better than
steam but were by no means perfect to
get them started you needed a lot of
muscle to wrestle with a hand crank and
even changing gears was a tall task
[Music]
this wasn't to mention that they were
noisy often vibrated and shook and
emitted an offensive odor
for these reasons electric cars were
seen as the best way forward in personal
transport they were whisper quiet easy
to drive and required relatively little
effort to run in addition electric cars
will perfectly fit for short trips
around the city as country roads weren't
suited for cars just yet they were too
bumpy and treacherous big names such as
Ferdinand Porsche founder of the Porsche
Motor Company and Thomas Edison went all
in on the electric trend in fact
Porsches very first car in 1898 was an
electric model known as the loaner
Porsche one year later
Edison set out in the mission to make
better longer-lasting batteries for cars
he believed that this form of transport
was clearly the future so he was
determined despite many attempts he
ultimately abandoned this vision a
decade later at the turn of the century
overall the car electrical otherwise was
seen as an expensive novelty only for
the rich they needed to be a way for the
common man to travel to and fro as he
pleased
cars needed to be affordable yet
mass-produced it would be a man named
Henry that would bring this into reality
Henry Ford thought hard about how cars
were produced and realised that
assembling a single car by a group of
three or four men was very inefficient
by observing the way in which meat and
tin factories were run he understood
that an assembly system would be much
better suited this system would only
have a person work on a specialized part
before that part moved on to the next
person down the line with the idea of
the assembly line he revolutionized the
car industry allowing cars to be
mass-produced for the first time this
brought the price down to an affordable
level by 1914 Ford was selling more cars
than all the other car manufacturers
combined a Model T sold for about two
hundred and sixty dollars or six
thousand four hundred dollars today
while an electric roadster sold for
around one thousand seven hundred
dollars or forty three thousand dollars
today
there was just no electric answer to the
cheaper gasoline Model T or was there as
it turns out there almost was this next
part is a story that's often lost in
history it was known that Henry Ford and
Thomas Edison were very close friends in
fact Ford used to work at edison's
lighting company when he created his
first experimental car in 1896
it isn't encouraged for to perceive this
path resulting in the Ford Motor Company
in 1914 the pair were working on an
experimental electric car he is Henry
Ford in an issue of the New York Times
January 11th 1914 quote within a year I
hope we shall begin the manufacture of
an electric automobile I don't like to
talk about things which are a year ahead
but I am willing to tell you something
of my plans the fact is mr. Edison and I
have been working for some years on an
electric automobile which would be cheap
and practical cars have been built for
experimental purposes and we are
satisfied now that the way is clear to
success the problem so far has been to
build a storage battery lightweight
which would operate for long distances
without recharging
mr. Edison has been experimenting with
such a battery for some time unquote
Edison's words in a 1914 issue of
automobile topics was interesting quote
I believe that ultimately the electric
motor will be universally used for
trucking in all large cities and that
the electric automobile will be the
family carriage of the future all
trucking must come to electricity I am
convinced that it will not be long
before all trucking in New York will be
electric end quote so the details of
what happened next are pretty sketchy
some people say that the experimental
labs for the electric cars were burnt
down in a fire others say that the oil
industry got to Ford but the most likely
explanation
that the batteries that Ford wanted to
use weren't capable of powering an
electric car
whatever the reason eventually the
project fell apart after 1.4 million
dollars of investment around 34 million
dollars today with a no cheaper
mass-produced model in sight this was
the beginning of the end for the
electric car the invention of the
electric starter which gained popularity
in the 1910s took the manual effort out
of starting a gasoline car this combined
with the cheap oil of the time all
impacted the viability of the electric
car further to this the quality of the
roads began to improve meaning that
people weren't just limited to
inner-city travel in the end it was all
too much and the superior range of the
petrol car was the final straw that
ultimately led to his downfall
the battery technology just wasn't there
throughout the decades many attempts to
bring both the electric car were made
perhaps none more infamous than General
Motors eveyone in the 1990s but as we
all know today the electric car is
finally here
after seeing what Tesla has done major
manufacturers such as Volvo Aston Martin
General Motors Jaguar and Land Rover are
all pledging to go electric
it really is funny the way things go
sometimes
so anyway that's it thanks for watching
I hope you learned something from this
video if you've just stumbled across
this channel feel free to subscribe this
has been - go go you've been watching
cold fusion and until next time I'll see
you again for the next video
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]